ho sentito il rumore della pioggia
scrosciante e bello sentirlo in questo
gioco ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj siamo
ritornati su ioniche pavimenti eravamo
rimasti che ho trovato l'uscita sembra
si possa uscire da qui mentre salgo la
scala cremoso convinto dovrei portare
takuro queen oggi ecco lo sapevo ma ci
avrei scommesso ma noi siamo delle brave
persone vero quindi li mortacci mia dove
riportarlo qui cioè non potevo uscire no
che c'era l'uscita no sono a tre stanze
da takuro ragazzi questa è la prima
questa è la seconda è quella è la terza
tanto succede qualcosa o no takuro c'è
c'è incredibile pensavo fosse morto
takuro ha sì ho trovato l'uscita di gesù
ma che mai sentito dici sul serio
testicolo sismico sul serio è entrato
nell'armadio anno takuro si è unito a te
amica per so forse trovato nell'armadio
tipo narnia vabbè si è unita ma grazie
quindi adesso sono a conta curo che
bello studente delle scuole medie ma ci
sono bambini questi ma mi chiedo se
fossero più grandi ok ragazzi sono a tre
stanze dall'uscita 12 audio non ci credo
3 o dai anno aspetta che lo gira
l'angolo
lo sapremo brutto stronzo che cosa sta
facendo
ma piccolo è caduto lo sapevate
era ovvio ancora non tappe rientrato zio
stai tranquillo e vabbè mi spiace devi
crepare e [ __ ] il karma ma
seriamente sarei mangiato in un secondo
fammi capire com'è possibile non la
cagato nuovi hanno salvato la partita
sono stai non ho salvato la partita lo
riferimento lo sto pezzo
papà cuore dai vai avanti veloce ok
ragazzi di proviamoci un'altra madonna
che brutto che allora fatemi capire una
cosa ma lui quando cadde il tipo stata
vicina riesce subito così allora l'ha
lasciato vivo cioè dopo che devo credere
che qualcuno sia vivo quindi puoi
smetterla di seguirmi che mi dai
consiglio grazie delle continuare a
gargano oggi e basta ha smesso
lo stesso cane da culo e non c'è o se
n'è andato senza di me scommettete come
far non esserci ma come fai a non è se
non può averlo mangiato impossibile
questa roba
ho trovato l'oggetto chiave della porta
sul retro porta sul retro quale porta
sul ma ndo vai vista dai non ci voglio
credere
ma va falco non puoi fare come nathan
drake che ti arrampichi sulle corna non
può niente la che ho trovato la chiave
della porta sul retro che non ho idea di
che cosa sia stata porta susa dove
affanculo vai il brutto deficiente che
paga dove sta portare a mediche si è
spaventato perché fa fuori arrivasti
versi nell'armadio si cagano pur i
mostri ma lei che mi diciture a porta
sul retro chiede indicazioni le cave che
sono andiamo via domani a rega e salva
la porta
minchia che aspettando lo sto ricordato
per cui vivere senza ricordarmelo non ce
l'avrei mai si farà c'entrano perché ci
ho messo una vita per quello me lo
ricordo devo chiusa la lampadina sulla
bambola meno male che oggi non mi sei
venuto a trovare signer perché sonoro
nella merda ma devo spegnere la luce per
forza all ombra anche qualcosa non
sempre a posto con questa tappezzeria ma
andata di culo
devo usare nel coso di nuovo forza
ecco la minchia ci ho messo una vita da
trovasta roba ragazzi ho trovato la
porta sul retro usate la chiave dalla
porta sul retro sono fuori bello il
genoa chiamatela un giardiniere
no non l'ho chiamato oggi faccio io se
mi lasci in pace faccio io ti prometto
che tipo un giardino più bello del
madison square basta che non mi ka che
cazzo gli piaceva l'idea del madison
square date la navata i muri quando
avete voglia non si apre ma non avevo
dubbi schiavo in un altro edificio un
altro ancora come se non solo non
ricordavo proprio cioè come se non
bastasse come se non ce ne fossero
abbastanza non gli edifici più avanti
vado il suo gioco diventa sempre più
tetro non si capisce perché permesso una
chiesa signora maria se vede un tizio
brutto passare qua dentro lo cacci ecco
fare ragazze pace un buco dove entra io
non entrerei mai però il buco è troppo
buio per vedere in basso e non entri
quindi troppo pericoloso scendere
minchia il primo personaggio di un
horror che adoro ragazzo si chiama
testicolo pensate che ironia della sorte
i buchi voi possono nascondere cose
brutte non pensate male di questa frase
bella staccata è molto varia
cos'è un punto di salvataggio questo no
no salve cipro stai calmo ma il ragazzo
6 dic le del tuo primo e vissuti al
pavimento a benzina che sta che però il
se n'è andato se offeso lavezzi che sta
a casa va a cagare
con loro ho capito questa roba sembra un
culo non si capisce che cosa sia vabbè
riusciamo posto entrare nel buco io
pensavo di uscire nella stanza di prima
invece no 5 dati con un 6 manca un sesto
da dove non so quindi niente giochi
d'azzardo frate porta aperta quindi qua
c'è una cosa con dei dati va bene
qualcuno ha per caso dei dati da
prestarmi la porta è chiusa
ti prego fa che questa sia aperta
mai lasciare un mostro coi pastelli ah
ecco perché è diventato blu perché se
spa stellato la faccia adesso è tutto
chiaro lega l'altro qua qua c'è una
porta per forza perché qua finisce
qualcosa non sembra posto in questa
tappezzeria amica si vede quanto mi è
servita scheggia di un piatto
dall'inizio del gioco può sapere è più
ordinata asta stanza che era nascosta
che quella di prima vabbè ho realizzato
troppo tardi ho realizzato troppo tardi
sono scemo o realizzato dopo tardi che
era entrato nell'altra pensavo fosse
invisibile consentito entrare qualcuno
con la porta non c'era invece era
entrato in quella di prima dovevo avere
il tempo di nasconderlo non c'erano ci
si arriva a uso stupido io abbia dei
pazienti
va beh meno male che salvo spesso perché
se no vai vai vai dai nas con i ci avevo
fatto proprio caso sta cosa
ciao zio torna pure a colorare coi
pastelli l'altra stanza frate perfetto
ci siamo ho detto l'altra chi devo
insegnare come fare i disegni no perché
se ti insegno io e grave ed e roma fatta
a colorarla in un attimo io sono stato
nell'armadio 10 secondi non è possibile
ho trovato l'oggetto dado ho trovato il
dato che luccicava tra l'altro che dado
eh
è un dato che luccica vabbè comunque non
ho capito come hai fatto a colorare e
disordinare la stanza in un secondo
impossibile hanno capito sarò la propria
esigenza grazie ho trovato un dato io
sono forte vado a giocare d'azzardo a
las vegas ci siamo ragazzi perfetto è
una scritta dove leggere no vabbè lo
scopriremo ragazzi perché non ho capito
c'è un voto ho capito c'è un bottone
premi il bottone sì questo è ma non me
li ricordo tutti ok a niente sarà è la
posizione delle panchine della chiesa
grazie maria emerito di maria che indica
la via ragazzino ho capito allora
destra sinistra in basso a sinistra in
alto a sinistra in basso a destra in
alto a destra
onoriamo c a destra e sinistra giù su
giù su grazia perché mica ci sarei mai
arrivato da solo diego permesso bella
sostanza amministra di uno scudo
torniamo indietro nel cos'è il medioevo
non spiega faccio una porta di sotto che
ha permesso
bello sono tutti uno più allegro
dell'altro stato di reagan o il quadro
di prima che non è un culo sembra una
freccia più che altro hub è che non ho
ancora capito che cosa servono però non
si apre ammesso sono fa vj bello mi
mancavano le stanze buie all hard
ah ok c'è una candela dai accendere con
affanculo
e vabbe dai come facciano un metro che
cazzo che straccia tutti
mamma mia come lo come scappo non fatica
perché prima come scappo allora sei
stronzo mare via per il culo ma è va
bene se quanto sopra le scale salire le
scale e sto deficiente nel buco nel buco
le buche non mi ha seguito ha smesso ha
smesso perfetto va bene perché deve
rompere sempre i maroni perché perché
ragazza quale criterio vi prego 9
accendersi cosa ci devo fare un altro
quadro era per questo per questo ho
rischiato la vita per del colore blu
cosa cambia dagli altri quadri cosa ho
trovato l'oggetto pezzo blu no niente
cambia al cup è no non mi rifiuto mi
rifiuto se spunta qualcuno mi incazzo
giuro è dai ragazzi non è che devo
dimettere il prezzo auchan hanno niente
volevo dove rimettere il pezzo perfetto
non detto comunque credo che ben si
servano per essere inseriti tutti qua
dentro credo è perché poi si apre quella
porta lassù non ne sono sicuro come
faccio a prenderlo se si chiudono le
porte ma immagino ci sia un altro quadro
con un altro pezzo o non mi sputa
madonna che di buio o non vedo niente
reti che la prigione veramente dovevi
accendersi e la mad o c'è una prigione
ragazzi questa no questa mi mancava
tanto sono tutte chiuderci qualcosa lì
c'è qualcosa di grande tra vino e non ho
la chiave quindi la porta è chiusa va
tutto chiuso e visto gioco ci manca solo
questo
questa ragazza è l'ultima porta poi non
so cosa aprire qualcosa mi dice che devo
tirare la tenda però non voglio farlo
addirittura c'è un pentagono una corda
che faccio mi impicco come takeshi ho
trovato l'oggetto corda ma grazie a cosa
mi serve un accordo da provare a
prendere a ok non farmi cielo 3
non lo so è però ci provo e un'idea che
mi era venuta prima però non ne sono
sicuro devo calarci la corda con
l'accendino funziona a ciò fatto proprio
la scala e quindi ragazzi che un crudo
più l'episodio di aoni spero che vi sia
piaciuto continuerà nel prossimo anno
bravo io concludere sempre nel momento
migliore quindi ragazzi se video
piaciuto ma se il documento non mi piace
anche la pace di facebook come lo sa
bene iscrizione sono serie di scatti ci
vediamo il prossimo vita dei ragazzi